[Music]
is it recording do this boom boom what's
up everyone welcome to simulation I'm
your host Don sake and very excited to
be talking about worldviews and public
intellectuals we have Julia Shay joining
us on well thanks for coming on again
very excited do the handshake I'm super
excited
Julia's visiting right now from
Cambridge she's a junior at Harvard yeah
she's a senior now at Harvard that's
right yeah okay here in the house here
okay and we've done two shows with you
before I've loved our conversations you
just came in and you were saying a
moment ago that you were looking at the
slogan of what I'm saying with
simulation rebirthday yeah look
intellectual yeah so every time I get an
email from you at the bottom of the
email is this quote or not quote slogan
I guess that says your rebirthing the
public intellectual and that really made
me think about how I think in today's
age we're sort of missing this figure
that we had in the past and that we
still look toward we don't have these
people like Bertrand Russell all of our
sacks all these people who I mean Oliver
Sacks was relatively recent but this
sort of like I like critical idea people
have sort of left and that I think is
what you're trying to do here and I
think what we were talking about is how
people like Donald Trump or people who
are extremely biased in their views
that's an extreme example have like
millions of followers on Twitter or
whatever YouTube whatever platform
they're using whereas people like you I
mean it could just be um that you
haven't been around as long as these
other people yet doing what you're doing
but have more the sort of the public
intellectual maybe is facing some sort
of difficulty getting attention or
followers or likes or whatever that is
and what is that pushback
yeah it was a great when you walked in
and you were just like rebirthing the
public intellectual let's talk about
that now it's like okay sounds good to
do it okay so there's a couple things
let's look at it historically first so
on a level of history this has been
happening for quite a long time is this
sort of during this disc in tribal era
that we had we had a lot of the time
someone that was a storyteller that was
wise within our kin within our tribe
that would help tell stories that was in
the best interest inclusively to
communicate a story that was important
for other people to hear and we've kind
of after a long period of evolution kind
of exploded in terms of population from
these kin tribes into this massive
interconnected global globalized
information technology world with eight
billion of us and now it's become a
little bit more difficult to find the
signal where you can end up having
someone that's just trying to self deal
by telling a story I'm just gonna tell
you something so that you pay me money
that I earn money and it doesn't even
need to be wise or not doesn't even need
to have a great signal or not so and
that's all the way from kin tribes from
100 plus thousand years ago all the way
through things like public intellectuals
that you were describing earlier also
ones that were maybe in these smaller
towns of 10,000 people that we're
developing all the way up to today where
you see this blue checkmark ecosystem of
verified users and you can occasionally
find a verified user that has an input
stream that's all hat that has been
multidisciplinary they balanced tons of
different world views and perspectives
and then you can have a blue checkmark
person that is extremely biased
extremely one-sided their input stream
has been just one side of a conversation
and they have millions of followers but
then you can find someone that only has
300 followers that actually has an input
stream that is the most
multidisciplinary the most balance of
worldviews and they're disseminating
really high-quality stuff but they are
only getting it out to a couple people
so this is part of the move
that we care a lot about is part of the
slogan is this rebirthing the public
intellectual and other part is inspiring
you to build the future and so when you
have a new connected globalized
information technology world you can
actually leverage the tool to be
extremely powerful for disseminating
high signal and how do we come up with
the consensus of what a signal tough but
we are totally on path to be figuring
that out and doing it with things like
this as well as other independent media
you were talking about it a little bit
ago you don't you and so many other
young people are like Julia came in and
she was like not just wanting to do
things that were mundane right that's
why she's even here in the first place
she came to Silicon Valley because she
knows that she can accelerate herself
intellectually at much faster rates by
being bicoastal by having a Cambridge
nodal cluster and a Silicon Valley nodal
cluster and so she's here doing that and
what she did is she immediately started
vlogging and she was vlogging about the
experience of being here in capturing
really good conversations between us
with Ron's stuff outside that she's
experiencing stuff that she's
experiencing and she started stitching
it into a movie this is what everything
this is the public intellectual this is
people that take life by the horns and
say I'm going to make content that
inspires people that no matter if I only
start with one follower that eventually
that becomes 2 4 8 16 and then we can
slowly but surely regain back control of
having a more cohesive unity on this
planet so that would be a tiny bit of a
mystery plus all the other IT stuff that
we're in for just that's just a public
intellectual side of things yeah I think
I one interesting question we'd sort of
have to do an experiment about this is
like is the public intellectual really
less popular at the moment than these
other people like is there are we biased
in favor of people who are biased and
rather than like interested in all
knowledge and I think like that's
something we're sort of assuming here
I'm not a hundred percent sure it's true
we'd have to sort of like go through
Instagram accounts and go through
YouTube accounts to really see whether
that's true and then you're just like
cognitive ease or cognitive bias right
yeah because it's as easy as saying that
if you provide me with a black or white
perspective on something I can more
easily just say aha but if you provide
me with this nuanced multi paragraph
explanation of something I'm gonna be
like oh it's so much harder to
understand yeah I think maybe it's just
that what we're talking about the type
of like inspiring content that we're
talking about like you're saying it
might be sort of like hidden in accounts
I think people can when they read it
they detect it and they're like ooh this
is good stuff but it's just not like
public enough so that's why I'm super
into what you're doing here I think one
thing though is it's really important
I've been thinking about this myself
sort of like figuring out what format
and how to organize this stuff to get it
out because I think what we're facing is
this issue of like we can have these
conversations that they can be lost
pretty easily and they can be buried in
40 minutes into a YouTube video or
whatever so I think figuring out like
how to make this stuff accessible so
that it can inspire people is so
important yes so that's taking content
like this and being able to do things
like make knowledge graphs make
transcripts of it do things like make
highlight reels of it make short clips
of it and with help of people like you
that actually watch the program we can
do things like that we just need the
couple extra teammates to come on board
and help us and things like that so and
the funding to move the ball forward and
we're slowly getting there and doing
that so I also want to illustrate out so
that's part of the equation is figuring
out the optimal modes of dissemination
of this content the optimal modes of
inspiring other people long-form is good
it gives them that option we also need
the transcripts knowledge graphs all
that stuff highlight reels etcetera
anyway yeah we move off of this but well
I want it I want it
you then you then in you elicited
another aspect of what I'm extremely
passionate about building in the long
term and I want to explain that now yeah
so in the long term if you take this
public intellectual movement and you
instead of saying that this is gonna be
something that's just gonna be on
Twitter and on YouTube and it's just
gonna be on on streams of content or
it's just gonna be in a Coliseum or in
an atrium or whatever it may be in a on
a stage in front of people that's good
that's good but I think this needs to go
to a global debate stage let me explain
what that looks like so it would be as
though a global debate circuit even it
would be as though within the United
States it's kind of like the the Prize
systems that existed a big crowd-sourced
incentive driven prize system so
something like a man and a woman let's
in this case I'll see you Julian Allen
as an example which would compete
against teams of other men and women
inside of the United States for one team
within the United States to represent
the US on a global level
same thing in Kenya and same thing in in
Latvia and same thing in in Thailand
just all different places around the
world would have a team of a man and a
woman that would compete against other
teams of men and women in order to have
a single have a language barrier hold on
let me let me let me let me this is a
that's a great point it's a great point
there's there's there's more here quick
just on a on a how this works level it
is a you take something like a complex
subject complex subject like a debate
topic like resolved the cost of social
media outweighs the benefits right
something that is controversial it's a
super nuanced and it doesn't have clear
answers it's not binary but but what
that does a results a min like that
the teams of people like Allen and Julia
would basically have to come prepare to
either fight for or against it so the
teams have to come completely prepare to
fight on either side of it to debate on
either side of it and then at the
beginning of the debate there's a coin
flip
that happens then that the team they get
to either pick they want to be pro or
con if they win the coin flip however
you want to figure out an rng can assign
it doesn't even matter at that point but
you only learn right before you go into
the debate then you have judges you have
a panel of judges maybe three or five
judges what they're doing is they're
listening to the persuasive arguments
between the two debate teams and they're
picking which debate team is best at
repre
so it's kind of like the big March
Madness brackets or the big World Cup
brackets that you just have a bracket
system that comes down to the final
global stages and then once you get to
this like World Cup of global debate
where it's just one team from every
country that then at that point you can
do things that are even more
geopolitical things like how like how do
we program ethics into super
intelligence or so questions like that
or how do we handle wealth inequality so
so these are some of the questions that
we could have lift up to debate stages
around the world and have it be then
have young people compete to be on these
debate stages and then have those things
streamed across the world and inspire
more people to to solve some of the most
pressing challenges that we face today
yeah okay yes so I have a few pieces of
feedback weighing about yeah so there
are a few things I think in terms of
inspiring people assuming this language
barrier wasn't an issue I think this
would be a great thing there are a few
other problems though the language
barrier isn't actually an issue the
language barrier is changing so quickly
there's the device already where I can
speak in Korean and out the other side
it comes out in English well and that
device is already existing so it's just
gonna get better and better over time
where it's not gonna be as big of an
issue yeah live translation on it yeah
go ahead the other thing is I think
before when we were talking about this
you mentioned that people would be
assigned to sort of a pro or con side to
this and I think what that would do is
essentially I think like what we're what
we're looking for here is we're looking
to inspire people but about
this whole format of debate and
conversation but what we're also looking
to do is to solve these problems that
people are debating and I think it
should be about the merit of the
arguments and so if you're assigning if
we get assigned to the con side of
social media costs outweigh the benefits
maybe that's the wrong side to be on
like I know it's not a binary issue but
maybe like really the better arguments
are in support of the other side and
this great point people new wants
instead of the binary yeah I think
people should be able to pick what side
they're on
and people that's maybe yeah okay go
ahead keep on you know what if I think
when people are picking a side they're
saying I support this viewpoint and then
they're able to point of doing pro and
con and having to study both sides is
that that's like what happens when you
steal man someone's argument that if if
I if I only live in social media is good
land I don't even know how to summarize
a social media is bad argument same
thing if someone lives in just social
media is bad land they don't know how to
steal man or summarize social medias
good arguments so that's what at least
having a coin flip at the beginning
would have people prepare it on both
sides but there's actually potentially a
better way to do this if we really want
to have everything that we're talking
about in this conversation show up in a
live knowledge graph that's being
painted of the nuance of the subject of
the costs outweigh the benefits or
however you want to state that resolved
statement that that is actually an
exceptional ideas that you could
potentially have the knowledge graph
being made in real time live of the
nuance that's being discussed between
the teams and the nuance is the most
important takeaway not which team wins
on pro or con right right I think what
you're like you bring up the point that
if you live in social media social media
is bad land you don't even understand
the arguments for social media is good
land I think one thing that would solve
that problem though is this question
about social media for example clearly
there are arguments on both sides
otherwise we wouldn't be having this
debate and so
zooom ibly somebody who's on one of
these debate teams would be a strong
argue or the other side and would be
able to introduce those arguments and it
would then go on the knowledge graph and
the nuance would be introduced etcetera
etc so I think the details of this
obviously have to be worked out but I
think public debate on like TV would be
so cool to watch maybe it exists and I
just don't know about it well the
closest thing I think we have right now
is the intellect intelligence squared
debate switch are pretty good they do a
decent job at this but this can be done
in an even better way and I think what
we're what we just got there in the last
sentence that you said was that last
couple sentences was that what happens
when you have someone that is extremely
deep on both pro and con on a specific
issue then after the coin flip they have
to debate on just pro or con is that
what they're doing is they're
structuring out the the most cohesive
arguments against the benefits of social
media the most cohesive arguments for
the benefits of social media and then
what you do is you package both of those
together into a knowledge graph on here
are the best benefits here are the worst
attributes of social media and then you
solve it becomes like an equation how do
you make social media 2.0 that takes all
of the good that was debated on the pro
side of these World Stages how do you
take all the bad and archive that code
update that code to make it even better
for 2.0 yeah yes if that's where things
like this could lead so this is the mix
between public intellectuals global
debate circuits nationally
internationally televising these one
other piece of feedback um I think that
the speech format could be interesting
for people to watch but also I think
there's some value as you know because
you're very involved in this in like the
sort of multimedia type approach to
argument or to content so I think having
this not being necessarily just like
like essentially what this is like a
verbal broadcast
instead having it be like like you could
have any format people could choose the
format
they feel as best it could be videos it
could be written content it could be
sort of like a post that incorporates
written content video audio etc yes I
think the approach thrive in the space
as well people to make videos people can
make write written examples yeah people
can submit just audio examples I just
it's just like if you want to submit
films right there's so many things that
you can submit into this it it's like
maybe you do have a film global circuit
where people take film and try to make
the nuance on the subject on a film
level that there's a winner from South
Africa and a winner from yeah well and
they ignore the two people per country
like I think this should just be a and
ignore even the idea of like a contest
with one winner I think like essentially
what you're doing is you're crowd
sourcing wisdom so you are taking the
best like it doesn't even have to be
like the best film somebody submits it
could be like just one like sentence or
one thirty second portion of a film that
someone submits you sort of compile all
of that content into one one new piece
of content one like a compiled piece of
content that has all of the good
arguments together and then we inform
policy based on that that's great yeah
so there's both the potential for it to
actually have humans in debate which i
think is still in a really really
interesting one I took a fuckload of
debate when I was younger and I think
it's one of the best ways to be able to
unpack the nuance and learn emotional
intelligence and so much I do still
think that's extremely applicable as
well as the applicability of having
things like films and books and other
things competing in the space and the
competition is more of a crowdsource
like you said who are the best examples
from the different parts of the world
and then how do we synthesize the best
examples into updating
the social fabrics code yeah updating
policy yeah that's great yeah this has
been a nice back and forth on the public
intellectual crowdsourcing of ideas to
update policies I like that a lot okay
let's hit on what you mentioned last
night
okay so teach us about what your stance
is on worldviews and certainty versus
uncertainty oh gosh okay let me see if I
can explain this so I think it started
out with this kind of rhetorical
question about is there a correct
worldview and before letting you answer
I basically answered it myself and I
said I think that when reality ceases to
surprise you you have achieved the
correct worldview and I think what that
means is that it doesn't mean that
everything is predictable but it means
that you've accounted for the
unpredictability of people of objects of
I mean not that objects are particularly
unpredictable but for the idea that like
a car could swerve for instance like an
object that's occupied by a person so
you've accounted for that
unpredictability and the world still
ceases to surprise you I think means
that you have like a correct worldview
there are a few like other nuances to
this I mean there are tons of nuances I
haven't thought about one is that
there's this really funny video I can't
remember what animal it was of it might
have been like a hamster or something
and basically like the hamster learns
that in order to get a food pellet it
needs to do like it needs to like turn
in a circle press a lever and climb up a
set of bars and then it gets the food
lover I mean it gets the food pellet
when in reality all the hamster needs to
do is just climb up the set of bars and
get the food pellet but it thinks that
there's this whole like elaborate
routine it needs in order to get the
food palate so that would be an example
of like a functional worldview but not
like a correct worldview and that it's
not them
parsimonious okay so let's take this
just take this and begin to unpack I
like where this is going and I think
maybe a good way to unpack this would be
to understand how things work so if you
have a worldview where you understand
how 90% of all things around the planet
are traded and moved by sea by sea
freight tell their locations when you
are able to understand on a emotional
intelligence level about how to get into
behind other people's eyes and try and
understand their input streams for their
whole life that got them to exactly
where they're at you build a deeper more
true understanding of how things work
how the economies and goods work how the
human beings work on an interpersonal
level so once you build out this more
true world view of how things work
including the things like if I was to
just be like right now and you'd be like
okay that was some one certain ship but
I predict that you're occasionally gonna
do some weird uncertain [ __ ] like that
yeah and that same thing like you said
when accidentally a car can swerve or
all these other things that you're
predicting them in that's why you don't
just walk around on the streets with
zero vigilance you walk around on the
streets with a little bit of vigilance
just in case something nuts happens yeah
so this type of stuff yeah
can I add one other thing about you so I
think I might have said like is there a
correct worldview and what I actually
meant is like
I think there's a correct worldview for
each person that's different so I think
the way you're born like what you look
like what your voice sounds like all of
these things like your DNA your seed
what I was going to say that good
yeah so I think that determines your
worldview
everybody has I think different
opportunities available to them not only
based on circumstance but I really think
based on DNA and so I think people's
worldview can be different so like for
instance like I think you're somebody
that believes in doing things in a
slightly more uninhibited way than I do
and I think there's a lot of value in
that you can send out tons of content to
the world and get feedback from the
world whereas I operate on like a
slightly more conservative like
conservative I operate from a more
conservative viewpoint essentially and I
think that oh no I should only put out
content that is really valuable to the
world and I think there are so many
different sources of this one could be
gender for instance I think I don't want
to make this into a gender argument I
think it's way more complicated that and
then that I'm just pointing out like one
little thing I think that maybe like
women or other under privileged groups
or whatever need to sort of prove
themselves more or something and so
there's more reason to cull and pick
your content and your self presentation
more carefully so it's as though this
seed of every single human that has
their own unique DNA in it
as that gets expressed into the world
that that becomes their optimal
worldview at their truest worldview so
it's as though it's as though that if
you have a seed that is meant to be an
artist if the seed is meant to be a
scientist if the seed is meant to be a
philosopher whatever the seed is meant
to do in this world that the closer
closer that you get to opening up the
doors for yourself that get you to the
artists because you were able to get the
tools when you were really young that
got you closer and closer to
understanding that arts what gives you
the most meaning in life that then your
world view becomes definitely more
centered on art it's not like you're
gonna somehow also end up knowing
absolutely everything about
macroeconomics at the same time but so
then this is how your worldview can
because you have a limited amount of
neural real estate you can't just sponge
up every single edge field at its
absolute lowest I think what I heard
this like recently I don't know if this
is true at all I think that there's some
sort of thinking that humans sort of
don't have a limit to the amount that
they can learn obviously we're limited
by time but in terms of like actual
content like assuming we lived forever
that there isn't actually like a limit
to how much our brain can learn
well there's so much nuance there I mean
what one of the points is like you
brought up time like you live for 80
years so that's first and foremost
yeah the next point is that it's just
it's hubristic to think that like you're
you know inputstream can somehow
encompass all that is so so we so then
probably the most humble way I think to
potentially approach it is to say
something along the lines of I will
identify what my unique seeds DNA is and
I will try and identify in the world as
much of an input stream
around that unique seeds DNA that I have
so that I can come out to have that as
true of a worldview for this seed as
possible yeah I think we're sort of
mixing up this idea of like optimal life
and worldview like in terms of like
career being optimal or whatever like
pursuit you take on in your life I think
it's different from worldview like true
like I don't I don't I don't have as
much of a hard cut line between career
and world view I think these things are
two world view is I think how you
understand like world view is your model
of how the world works and your career
gets totally embedded within your career
informs your worldview
okay okay I think we can get lost in
words but but I think that I think it's
important we keep the the concept
separate I think they're different what
you do every single day in your career
totally informs your worldview but but
at the same time it's as though it's not
like a okay fine sure you can separate
and say like my worldview can be reading
books that don't have anything to do
with my career we know a worldview is
not an activity a worldview is no box I
know okay yeah a worldview is exactly
what you have at this given moment based
on the inputs that you've taken in in
your life point being is that if one
thinks that they can just somehow
separate career from worldview they can
no of course yeah so so that's why I
said there's no binary division for me
between those two things
that's why yeah yeah I'm getting a
little lost in the words we are yeah
yeah yeah I think the most important
point that we were trying to hammer
there is that the more that you
understand how things work and how
humans work how economies work how the
planet biology evolved to get to the
point that it does today
the more that you understand the truth
of those things the more that you have a
true worldview then we said that the
seed if you care more about art or
science or philosophy or wherever you
care more about your potentially you can
have a more true worldview for what your
seed fullest actualization is in the
world I think those are some of the key
points that was good though that you
came up and said like certainty around
how things work as part of a worldview
and also taking into account uncertainty
yeah that was all good I think so
going back to this idea of uncertainty I
think there are sort of two sources of
uncertainty there's one source that's
just people animate objects are
unpredictable so like we I don't know
everything about you
you to be able to predict what you would
do next fully I don't know whether
you're gonna blink next or whether
you're going to start talking it cetera
and I think another source of the
uncertainty is lack of knowledge so
that's tied in to
what I just said like I don't have
perfect knowledge I don't live inside
your brain so I don't have perfect
knowledge but there's sort of another
branch of this imperfect knowledge is
like for instance like I don't know
stuff about geopolitics so my worldview
on geopolitics is really really unformed
so that's like a different kind of
unpredictable so I like or the economy
so the economy could like collapse
tomorrow and that wouldn't surprise me
that much because I have a huge
uncertainty allowance for stuff in the
economy just because it's not what I
read about so you know what I mean like
so and I mean those are actually sort of
the same thing it's that lack of
knowledge is creating our uncertainty
allowance or causing us to need to allow
for uncertainty I agree with that that's
that's really good way to put it so you
can be at the edge of knowledge across
different fields and you can potentially
if you're really deep in neuroscience
let's just take you as an example if
you're really deep in psychology and
wanting to care and understand about
other humans and understand about their
input streams and who they became as
humans all this type of stuff you're
really deep in like say psychology
neuroscience and human behavior and
stuff and so with the subject like
geopolitics your area of uncertainty or
economics is just larger like you
explained okay at the same time I think
that adds potentially a little bit of
creativity if everyone's like this is
how the economy works I've already been
studying it for 20 years and then you
come and you're like well why doesn't it
work like this
Oh absence somebody could be like hmm
I'm actually really open mind of that
and that could be really good also at
the same time I think that you might not
actually be that if you are all the way
at the edge of something like psychology
neuroscience and human behavior that it
is potential that you still have quite a
bit of uncertainty not in the sense that
as much as potentially something like
geopolitics or economics but maybe in
the sense that something could happen at
the edge of your field that could push
even further and that kind of actually
is saying to that example of a newbie
coming in and saying something a newbie
could come into your field and say
something
but there is still a degree of
uncertainty it could potentially be less
like you're explaining if you're really
sophisticated in one area one worldview
though encompassing all of these complex
fields let's say from all that is we can
say that I'm trying to have a world view
of all that is okay then the question
would be what makes up the most true
world view of all that is how do you
teach a child when they're born into the
world the most true world view of all
that is and then let them also
simultaneously be figuring out this is
what I want to creatively express into
the world but right now we're not even
doing that we're not taking and saying
that we evolved on this rock together
we're not saying that that that eight
billion of us all have different
perspectives and different life stories
and different amounts of trauma growing
up because we didn't have the right
nutrients and different creative
expressions the contributions to the
world so it's as though we're missing
one of the most critical pieces of world
views which is taking what is the most
true world view of all that is of our
reality and trying to get that to kids
when they're born into the world yeah I
think I think what you're asking is sort
of how do we set kids up to have a true
world view is that the question you're
asking so I think we're limited by time
in the world as we were talking about
and I think we don't have to force kids
on like what worldview they should adopt
because again everybody's going to have
a different worldview but then we
evolved here on this rock together what
does that mean do we evolved here on
planet earth together yeah every human
that's ever birthed and died evolved on
this planet yeah so I think children
should be taught that right are you
saying like as opposed to people who
like don't believe in evolution sure or
there are so many other examples like
this like we can't just believe that for
some reason that that we're good and
China is bad right these binary ways
perceiving the world dozer this is just
not a true statement when someone is
trying to see something like that so
when you say that actually the u.s. is
both good and bad
China is both good and bad yeah
everyone's everyone on the planet is
both good and bad then you're starting
to get closer and closer to truth
what are the good codes from us what are
the good codes from China how do we help
uplift these good codes archive the old
things yeah these types of crime to
always be good and bad or are we
suggesting that we can sort of leverage
all the good aspects of the world and
create a world that's all good it's a
great question
I think nothing is impossible so yeah so
hopefully we'll figure out what this
absolutely exceptional outstanding code
is and we'll bring that forth at its
fullest and if someone says hey I don't
think that code is that exceptional then
we'll say please teach us why the code
is not that exceptional maybe there's a
great way to update it I mean yeah I
think what you're talking about is a
meritocracy of idea of ideas true
meritocracy of ideas yeah not you have a
different idea so we're gonna burn you
yeah yeah it's an old arcade I think I
mean this is very like Freudian kind of
but what gets in it like that idea that
you're saying like your idea gets in the
way of my idea I'm gonna burn you that's
like our ego that's saying this hurts my
ego to let go of this idea that I have
one's open-mindedness we've talked about
several times as a major key in being
able to take and balance so many
different worldviews so many different
variables come up with new new lines of
code okay and then maybe the last thing
that we should talk about is nutrition
yeah you actually asked me this the last
time we sat down together and the second
time we sat down to the other night and
I said that it's
I want I want I want to refine my answer
and say that I think exercise and
nutrition are unique to that seeds oh
yeah Express expression to the world yet
I think that one can say that if you
think there's that weird place called
the Heart Attack Grill in Las Vegas
where if you're like over 350 pounds you
eat for free so it's just like you can
get caught in a [ __ ] weird system
where you buy junk food and fast food
and high fructose corn syrup and then
when you become 400 pounds and then the
idea is then you can use a phrase like
it's my seeds unique DNA to be 400
pounds so I want to also balance out
perspectives like that so that's why
when I give you the first response which
was you can tell how you feel if you eat
a burger or feed a salad you can tell
how you feel if you go on a run versus
if you don't you can tell how you feel
do you think your heart and brain thank
you more when you sit on your ass or
when you go on a run yeah and so yeah
and which one gets you how many more
years of life does a salad extend does a
burger slowed cut off a couple even days
of my life does not going on a run cut
off a couple days of my life I mean I
think it would be great if we could
quantify that stuff and use that as
information to empower people to make
more informed choices I think part of it
I don't know maybe I think yeah there's
stuff online that's like smoking a pack
of cigarettes is like minus X number of
days I think having that information
more available probably would be really
effective I'm sure there's behavioral
economic stuff to back that up yeah I so
I think and you were also talking
basically about or one thing we were
talking about earlier is that people are
sort of like roped into this system of
eating crap and then suffer from it
without choosing I mean it's like what
do we subsidize in this country like
corn we like feed corn everything
we have foods that are the foods that
are the cheapest are the unhealthiest so
essentially if you're not swimming in
money to spend on food you're gonna be
eating crap and I think it's a huge
failing of our society that that's the
way it is so I was suggesting that maybe
we should have like federally subsidized
like smoothie bars and I know this
sounds like the most like extra thing
ever because smoothies have been
associated with lots of sort of like
cultural privilege but the point is is
that it's like a nutritional drink with
fruits vegetables and like healthy
protein and that's sort of like at least
I think based on current nutritional
knowledge like kind of a fact so if we
had things that I I so I I hesitate to
say we should like ban bad foods because
I think we should be able to eat them in
moderation like you should be able to
have birthday cake and not have it like
we don't want a black market for bad
foods but at the same time I think what
we should do is sort of push forward the
things that are nutritional and make
them readily available and easy too easy
to pay for so that means like smoothie
bars on every corner and then people
won't go into the convenience store and
buy chips yeah there's some interesting
nuance here is that if you take
something that's as complex as the
microbes that have evolved inside of
your gut and you and your oral
microbiome your gut microbiome if you
really think about the billions of years
of evolution for those microbes and then
just the these past couple millions and
hundreds thousands of years of humans
evolution a lot of people I apophis eyes
that it could be that we are actually in
service to our microbes and so that the
amount of will that you think that you
have yourself of deciding when you open
the fridge to grab this or grab that is
actually quite a bit lower than your
microbes are allowing you to do so those
microbes actually have a significant
amount of complexity to them that we're
only
to understand things like if the
smoothie bar mentality you can somebody
I can actually not do something like
fruits that well if someone could not do
something like vegetables that well yeah
and so that means that do they need to
eat a diet that is more heavy and carbs
instead yeah that's actually possible
that's why this idea of universally
healthy food is in many ways starting to
be understood as is that potentially
more of a myth does every single one of
us have a different microbiome that debt
is actually that could be better but I
agree that there are definitely things
like high fructose corn syrup that you
can literally say that me drinking 50
grams of sugar inside of a coca-cola is
probably not as good okay empirically
not as good as if I was to drink
something like water or drink something
like that that subsidized fruit and
vegetable smoothie that is likely
potentially also just want to make sure
for those that are that caught the word
federally just it doesn't necessarily
have to be federally not subsidizing
subsidized sure yes yes yes some people
through yeah there's so many other ways
to figure out how to do it yeah I think
you're raising a really good point that
we all sort of have cravings for
different things that are probably based
in our biology like you might need for
some reason your body might need more
salts than a mine and so you and that's
actually healthy for you so for instance
like something like that so I think like
definitely like working with that
possibility is important and and
creating the variety of options that
accounts for that those differences is
something that we could do it's just
that we would basically be
de-emphasizing the foods that are on
average universally bad I think there's
also potential yeah
average Universidad sure sure there's
like high fructose corn syrup was one of
them another one is Patraeus fat I mean
that's basically banned already yeah
potentially something like the
carcinogenic effects of smoking
cigarettes and there's yeah versus
something there was some nuance there to
smoking a tobacco leaf completely you
know
yeah we're different okay we can
continue more on other follow-up
conversations while you're visiting that
was good world views public
intellectuals nutrition yeah I'm glad
that we were able to unpack some good
new anse there you helped me a lot
because now I'm able to synthesize and
structure better which is why you know
we do this and hopefully those that are
watching also had something good that
came up so any any other last thoughts
from you Julia I don't think so
alright thank you everyone for tuning in
we really appreciate it love to hear
your thoughts in the comments below on
what we talked about drop us your
thoughts bat down there also share the
content with more people go talk to your
friends your families your co-workers
people online on social media about
world views public intellectuals
nutrition get talking more about these
things bring these up as questions in
your social groups more often ask them
as questions and also support the
artists entrepreneurs the organizations
around the world that you believe in in
your community supports simulations so
we can help grow our links are below
help these ideas keep spreading and go
and build the future everyone manifest
those dreams into the world thank you so
much for tuning in and we will see you
soon peace